>> Bret: ROSENSTEIN OVERSEES
THE INVESTIGATION NOW INTO
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE, ALLEGED
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE BY THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN INTO THE 2016
ELECTION.
NEW QUESTIONS TONIGHT OVER FIRED
FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY'S
FRIENDSHIP WITH A COLUMBIA LAW
PROFESSOR AFTER FOX NEWS LEARNS
THAT PROFESSOR ALSO HAD SECURITY
CLEARANCE.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE REPORTS ON
WHETHER A LINE MAY HAVE BEEN
CROSSED.
>> AN EMAIL TO FOX NEWS,
COLUMBIA LAW PROFESSOR DANIEL
RICHMAN CONFIRMED HE WORKED FOR
THEN FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY AS
A SPECIAL GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE.
KNOWN BY THE SHORTHAND SGE.
ON AN UNPAID BASIS.
SOURCES FAMILIAR WITH RICHMAN'S
WORK SAY COMEY ASSIGNED HIM A
SPECIAL PROJECTS.
HAD A SECURITY CLEARANCE AND
BADGE ACCESS.
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS WANT MORE
ANSWERS.
>> MAYBE WE NEED TO TALK TO
MR. RICHMAN UNDER OATH IN FRONT
OF MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY AND
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES.
WOULD'VE BEEN NICE IF WE
WOULD'VE HAD A FULL
UNDERSTANDING OF THE FULL
RELATIONSHIP MR. COMEY HAD WITH
THE GUY WHO ORCHESTRATED THE
LEAKS.
>> DURING HIS JUNE 2017
TESTIMONY, COMEY DID NOT
DESCRIBE RICHMAN AS AN FBI
EMPLOYEE.
THE FORMER DIRECTOR TESTIFIED HE
GAVE THE MEMOS, DOCUMENTS AND
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PRESIDENT, TO RICHMOND KICK
START WHAT'S NOW THE MUELLER
PROBE.
>> I ASKED A FRIEND OF MINE TO
SHARE THE CONTENT OF THE MEMO
WITH A REPORTER.
I DIDN'T DO IT MYSELF FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS BUT I ASKED
HIM TO BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT
MIGHT PROMPT THE POINT OF A
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE WHO IS A
PROFESSOR AT COLUMBIA LAW
SCHOOL.
>> AND OTHER SPECIAL GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEE WOULD COME UNDER
SCRUTINY, HILLARY CLINTON EIGHT
HUMA ABEDIN.
SENATOR CHUCK GRASSLEY AMONG
OTHERS PREVIOUSLY QUESTIONED THE
SPECIAL STATUS OF HUMA ABEDIN
THAT ALLOWED HER TO WORK AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND PRIVATE
SECTOR AT THE SAME TIME.
THE FBI DECLINED TO ANSWER
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT
RICHMAN, FOX NEWS UNDERSTAND
RICHMAN WOULD SEND TALKING
POINTS ON THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION COMPARING AND
CONTRASTING THE USE OF AN
UNSECURED PERSONAL SERVER FOR
GOVERNMENT BUSINESS.
THE CASE OF RETIRED
GENERAL DAVID PETRAEUS AND SANDY
BERGER, THE LATE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR UNDER
PRESIDENT CLINTON.
SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS THAT SOME
OR ALL OF THIS BEAUTY MEMOS WERE
SHARED WITH AT LEAST ONE OTHER